it's great to be joined today by cari
Blake injure who's a criminal justice
reporter for the Houston Chronicle she
spent two years in correctional
facilities and now exposes problems
within them something we talk about
often on the program Kari thanks for
talking to me really appreciate it
thanks for having me so let's start with
some of the work that you do now when
you talk about exposing problems within
the criminal justice system what is your
perspective as to what the primary
problems are as someone who has been
within the system because from outside
we could focus on nonviolent
incarceration we could talk about the
way inmates are treated we could talk
about the school to Prison Pipeline
private prisons there are so many
different directions we could go what's
your perspective given your relationship
to the system well I mean I think that's
a question with a lot of answers in
terms of what the problems are I mean
there's a lot of problems with indigent
defense with you know prosecutions with
wake or to run I mean I focused a lot on
the prison system because that was
something that in Texas was really not
being covered in any substantive way I
think and I think that's partly because
the Texas prison system is so spread out
it's you know 104 prisons across the
state it's sort of not local news to any
one particular paper because they're all
over so it you know I would hesitate to
say that this is sort of one of the
biggest problems in criminal justice or
anything but it is something that was
not being covered so I've delved into
conditions and you know medical care for
inmates and some aspects of Prisons that
just weren't being covered can you talk
a little bit about your life story and
how you ended up serving two years and
then maybe we can talk about what you
experienced firsthand yeah sure so I was
a heroin addict off and on for nine
years and then when I was in school I
was trying to finish up college despite
you know despite daily drug use and I
ended up getting arrested with a few
days left before I was supposed to
graduate and I went to prison for two
years and you know so I mean I
out and ended up getting my life
together and becoming a reporter and
it's you know it not the most common
outcome from incarceration and I was
incredibly lucky they you know afforded
this opportunity to rebuild my life yeah
what was different I mean as you're
alluding to and as we've talked about
the transition out is an extraordinarily
complex and sort of fraught with
difficulty situation an under-resourced
circumstance for sure what was different
about your transition out that allowed
you to do what you're doing now well I
mean there's a lot of things that were
different I mean for one I came in with
an education almost completed so when I
came out I had you know like two classes
left to graduate and then I had a degree
which I mean that enough itself is is
huge I also had support a family I had a
place to say you know I think they you
know white privilege plays a role I
think that uh you know class privilege
play plays a role and it was still hard
I mean I had all these advantages and
it's still hard to rebuild your life
with a felony regardless but I was very
fortunate during your time during those
two years talk a little bit about the
conditions you experienced not that
they're exactly representative of what
everybody experiences of course and talk
a little bit about maybe the solitary
confinement experience as well right so
yeah conditions do vary a lot from one
prison system to the next but there are
certain things that I think are somewhat
consistent you know medical care is
problematic in a lot of states and you
know and then for me the use of solitary
confinement was was really difficult I
was in solitary maybe three different
times for just a few days each and I did
not handle it well one of them was just
like routine medical isolation and then
one was because I'd been transferred and
one time was punitive and you know I I
just I remember the first time I
went in there and you know they'd close
the door behind me in it with this like
neon why like maddeningly neon white
cell and you know you have no clock it's
freezing in there you have like nothing
to do and you know I I just I just lost
it like I a very quickly lost track of
sort of time and like when I was awaking
when I was it was I was it was like
being buried alive I think I've said
that before
and that's really sort of the best
descriptor I think a lot of people sort
of think of solitary confinement as like
oh I like spending time alone in
solitary wouldn't be that bad but you
know I like spending time alone it's not
like that at all yeah I mean it seems
that no matter what the emotional state
of someone before that that there is no
way to justify that as part of a system
that's meant to rehabilitate I mean I
just don't see any way that that that
would be something that you could
justify with any kind of in any kind of
serious way well I mean I don't think
there's much way to claim that it's that
it helps from a rehabilitative
standpoint I mean typically the
justification that that prisons would
use is that it's about the safety and
security of the facility yeah but you
know I mean that that varies there's
different you know there's different
reasons that systems put people in
solitary confinement
and you know which which means that
there's sort of different issues to
address in terms of how it's being used
and how it should or shouldn't be used
so maybe we can start with like what you
would consider maybe some of the lowest
hanging fruit based on your experience
and the day to day problems that you had
what are the the sort of easiest
problems that could be fixed well I
think I think that varies a lot from one
prison system to the next you know I
think in you know I think in in Texas
one of the things that I'm seeing is
that you know a lot of the problems that
I'm hearing about here sort of stem from
from understand
laughing you know things like prison
violence and you know that there's been
a lot of pervasive issues with like drug
smuggling and you know it seemed and and
you know lack of medical treatment which
sometimes it's just because there aren't
enough staff to handle in getting people
to medical appointments and you know I
think it's probably unexpected for you
know a former inmate to be saying well
you need more guards but that does seem
to be one of the problems that we're
seeing here in Texas and part of that's
because they're not certified peace
officers so they don't get they don't
get very good pay compared to other
states or compared to you know other
state government jobs even so it makes
it hard to retain them but you know New
York didn't have that problem so I mean
this is you know they're much better
staffed like in terms of officer to
inmate ratio and you know I think I
think there are two say oh this is one
likes like this is the biggest problem I
think there was some specific prisons
that had extremely problematic cultures
there and I've written about some of
them and I've experienced some of them
and you know another thing that I think
part of that relates to is about the
placement of these humans and that
something is true in many states is that
a lot of the prisons are in extremely
rural areas and I think that can be
problematic for a number of reasons
including that you can end up in a
situation where the you know the you end
up with a bunch of you know old white
men guarding a bunch of young minority
inmates from urban areas and I think
that that has in some situations posed
its own problems and you know then you
end up with the inmates being further
from home so to sum that up I think that
the location of Prisons is problematic
and I think that the understaffing
issues have been consistent concern and
that's not even touching on like the
specifics of unaddressed medical issues
or you know civil rights issues which
are you know a whole other can of worms
if we widen our
scope a little bit beyond prisons to the
criminal justice system and that's also
something I mean you're covering prisons
you're also covering the criminal
justice system of course what do you
think the priorities should be in terms
of our elected officials when it comes
to the criminal justice system and this
is I mean it's wide open right war on
drugs plea deal industrial complex take
it any any way you want
well I mean I mean as a reporter I can't
really weigh in on you know what policy
changes I think should occur you know I
can as in you know the case of what I
just said prisons I can sort of weigh in
on what I see that keeps coming up as an
issue but I you know I have to maintain
neutrality here I can't start
recommending policy changes can you talk
a little bit let me see how I can
reframe it if we look at the current
Justice Department have you seen
anything take place that is any kind of
significant shift in policy and whether
you want to assign good or bad to it
that's your call but what what are the
sort of key changes we've seen in terms
of criminal justice under the current
Justice Department well I think it's not
just the current Justice Department but
I mean obviously everyone is seeing this
you know long term shift away from the
tough on crime attitudes of the 90s and
you know I mean that's been you know as
someone who was like directly impacted
by the you know war on drugs you know
that that's been interesting to see in
New York in particular and again this
has not been under the current Justice
Department because this would be about
state law you know they rolled back the
Rockefeller laws which were some of the
most notoriously punitive mandatory
minimum sentencing laws in the country
and they rolled those back progressively
over a number of years and I very
narrowly avoided being sentenced under
those because I got arrested about a
year after the last parts of them were
were taken off the books and you know I
could have been doing 15 to life had I'd
been sentenced under the old law so and
you know now with you know now we're
seeing like federal legislation that
would you know do things
reduce the crack cocaine the crack
powder sentencing disparity so I mean I
think we've seen this happen in various
states and you know we're seeing some
you know change on the federal level and
you know yeah it's happening some of
it's happening under this administration
but this is part of a longer trajectory
stepping away from a tough on crime era
can you talk a little bit about in your
conversations with other people who were
in the system when you were in the
system
how much discussion was there about this
type of stuff about policy about
sentencing about the types of things
that you're you're doing a lot of
coverage of I don't part of its because
of when I was in I I suspect that might
be different now like I was doing my
time like 2011-2012 you got to figure
you know it takes a couple years for the
major discussions on the outside to sort
of percolate through the prison's so I
suspect that now now things like the war
on drugs or stepping back from the war
on drugs might be getting you know more
discussion in prison than they were when
I was there but you know also to an
extent like you know you're in you're
already there like you're already stuck
in prison like I think for a lot of
people there's some sense of like how
much do we want to talk about how
terrible terrible this office you know I
mean that's kind of what it felt like
you know we talked about conditions and
you know there's a lot of sort of
dreaming about various lawsuits people
would like to see happen but there's not
a lot of discussion about policy change
Kenny Blankenship is doing excellent
work for the Houston Chronicle as a
criminal justice reporter Kerry I really
appreciate you talking to us today
thanks for having me